I'm very intentional in showing up very
black very fem all the time because
that's who I am however you feel like
showing up I hope you're able to do that
because there's so much freedom in it
you know when you when you haven't had
that kind of Freedom it is so difficult
to be able to actually do the good work
you know there are folks who you know
were were in my DMs and messages and
comments in August when I got you know
when I was announcing this job who said
oh well you think that the global CMO
should I'm sorry should do what come
again one more time because no I don't
think so yeah yeah the global CMO of
Netflix looks like this that for me is
the freedom to be able to be as I am so
that all of my energy can be put into my
Brilliance that's what I want that's
freedom